but for now I want to kick things off
with a question that Aaron had asked in
the Q&A and got a lot of upvotes and
that was s what role do you envision
generative AI having an education Beyond
just AI enabled software and apps as it
pertains to the whole of the future
educational
model oh yeah that's a that's a big
question um there there's so so I'm
actually writing a book about this it'll
be released in May called Brave new
words hopefully you all like the title I
didn't think of it um my book agent came
came up with the title um but I I
actually think you're going to see it
affect nearly every dimension of our
lives in in some way shape or form uh
there's the things that many of y'all
have already experienced um through kigo
and there's I can give you a sense of
where we think this is going to go
obviously we talk a lot about kigo being
a tutor uh kigo being a teaching
assistant uh expect to see more supports
for parents to think about how U AI can
can help them out uh um expect uh we're
working on ways that kigo actually can
transcend Khan Academy uh so imagine you
know already you can watch a video on
Khan Academy and ask kigo like hey why
do I need to learn this or you know can
you quiz me on this or can you summarize
this imagine if you had kigo with you
wherever you went on the internet uh
imagine a world and you know this is all
stuff we're working on where a teacher
or a parent could assign things through
conmigo uh can say hey you know right
now there's activity where you could
talk to historical characters but what
if a teacher said I want all my students
to uh talk to Marie krie and try to see
if they can identify this mystery
element uh and then kigo works with the
students on it and then is able to
report back to the teachers on how the
students did in that simulation uh so
you I definitely see all of that I see
uh hopefully helping teachers lives with
lesson planning grading um I think it's
going especially for things like grading
it's always is going to be important
have a teacher in the loop but the AI
could help a lot progress report writing
uh expect to see more functionality for
parents where not only can parents use
kigo to monitor uh what what students
are doing but also you know get get help
get advice as a parent I'm a parent like
how come my kids aren't going to bed on
time or how come they don't seem to
listen to me or you know what whatever
it might be um so those are I would say
the the near end and of course from a
technological point of view I think it's
we're only not too far away you're going
to have conversations with the AI you'll
even be able to have video conferences
with the AI things like this I think um
you you you fast forward even more we
have another sister nonprofit which we
started called
schoolhouse.com
we're able to give free tutoring because
uh the the tutors are volunteers we have
a whole mechanism of vetting them but
we're already using AI to give those
tutors feedback on how they could make
those tutoring sessions better so I
could imagine in the education space and
we have to be careful here we don't want
it to feel like big brother is watching
every educator that's not the spirit of
this at all but if they can help an
educator maybe while even potentially
while they're teaching say hey by the
way a bunch of qu students just had
questions on this topic I answered it
for them but you might want to double
click on that or hey you want me to
break them up into breakout groups and
then I can help moderate I the AI could
help moderate each of the breakout
groups so I think you're going to see a
lot more AI facilitation between human
being beings in the real world which I
think is is is very very exciting um and
it's not going to be limited to text
interfaces I already talked about speech
Vision there there there's there's a lot
of places it can go I you know we can
daydream in 10 years in the future what
it might do with things like virtual
reality Etc uh but but yeah it's I think
the world of assessment is going to
change dramatically because of AI uh
right right now standardized assessment
is fairly narrow in what it can do it's
historically either you type in a number
or you have multiple
choice because you it's hard to do
anything else at scale but imagine a
world in five years where you could go
through a simulation you could have a
conversation uh go through a Socratic
dialogue with an AI and at that point
maybe the AI can be pretty good
benchmarking in a standardized way we
have to be very careful about things
like bias Etc uh but I think I think
there's there's ways that we can we can
get there I can keep going but I I'll
stop there so we get more questions in
that's awesome that's a great way to
kick things off you know we'd love to
hear a little bit more about you so what
I would love for you to let us know is
how are you using kigo so far so come
over to that poll you know obviously
there's so much you can do with it
there's the tutoring side the creative
writing side even college applications
go ahead and take that poll on the
screen right now let us know how you're
using the tool today because we're
always curious to make it better even
more effective for all your use cases so
folks using it for tutoring of course
teaching college applications a lot of
teachers on the line S so that's awesome
um okay great well thank you for sharing
that I'll share those results with you
so you can look at that and then let's
go to a question from um from Jorge so
Jorge says s do you think the general
level of ability for the workforce on
mass will gradually need to improve
because of the Advent of AI there's lots
of interesting questions about AI the
workforce the labor market so curious to
get your thoughts here you know I I I I
sure hope so uh you know there's been
there's been some folks in the AI debate
who have said oh generative AI can
already do this it can write a paper can
I guess no one has to learn that stuff
anymore and I'm like no it's the exact
opposite because I think we do recognize
that this will be able to help us write
software or code or create art but and
and it can Elevate someone who might
have been a staff level writer to being
an editor because they can now have a
staff writers of AIS or someone who was
going to be an entry-level coder could
now be a software architect but but the
reality is you can't be a great editor
and chief if you can't write well and if
you can't manage and give feedback to
your writers and which this case some of
the writers might be artificial
intelligence uh so I think the
imperative for folks to be able to their
their skill competencies to keep up with
the AI is actually really really really
really important uh you know as as there
there's these frames going on like
you're not going to get replaced with an
AI but you might get replaced with
someone who is leveraging an AI um who's
using it as an extension of themselves
and I think best way to leverage AI is
if you're able to go up the the skill
chain as opposed to deskill yourself um
so so I I I think you know I talked a
lot about this even before AI really
came on the scene but I think it's even
more imperative we historically had an
industrial age labor pyramid uh where at
the bottom you have a lot of Labor in
the middle you have I guess you could
say the information processing class
white collar jobs Etc and at the top of
the pyramid you had um
researchers professor offers
entrepreneurs doctors lawy you know
teachers you know all like the highly
skilled Folks at the top we know what's
happening AI is going and Robotics to
some degree are going to collapse those
bottom two layers at the same time we're
going to have a massively more
productive society and so we have a
social question do we want all of that
increased productivity to only ACR to
you know I don't know 10% of the
population that's not a stable situation
that's not a happy situ that's a
dystopian situation and you might have
some type of redistribution but I don't
think most people want to just get a
check uh they want to be able to
participate and have a sense of purpose
and a sense of meaning and I think the
only way that you're going to do that in
this AI inflection point is by moving as
many people to the top of that labor
pyramid as possible and it it might
sound optimistic or even delusional but
a couple of things one the tools are
getting better and better and better and
AI is going to be able to help us do
that uh the other thing is I I always
point out if you go back 500 years in
time 20 30% was about how many people
could read even in Fairly literate parts
of the world and topics like algebra or
geometry were considered very fancy
esoteric topics um and you fast forward
today we expect um we expect pretty much
everyone to learn how to read by the
time they're say seven or eight years
old and we expect you know unfortunately
it's not as happening as much as we
would like but we' expect everyone to
understand something like algebra um at
at at some point and and so the fact
that we've already moved societ this
much forward I think if if I were to say
how many people are under capable
understanding quantum physics or writing
the next great novel or starting the
next major company right now folks might
say oh 5 10% Max well what if what if
through education we could make that 50%
or 80% of of people are capable of it I
I actually think we we we have to try
with that said I think there's always
going to be um I think the jobs that are
very human Centric are are going to be
in very very safe in this AI world uh
you know I've said it multiple time I
think teaching is actually going to be
one of the safest uh jobs and I'd like
to imagine it's going to get it's going
to it's going to become even more
valuable as we go into this world
because the AI is going to be able to
take do a lot of the um the minutia of
it and a lot of the coordination but the
value of a student being able to feel
like that caring thoughtful adult who
also has content masters is helping them
coaching them forming a connection with
them is huge I I was just reading a
study about the value of even having the
same teacher for two years in a row
right um you know so that to me says it
all uh that that that that relationship
aspect and I think there's going to be
other fields where that human aspect of
it is can only be Amplified if you can
do other things with with AI that's
awesome yeah I saw that Adam Grant had
called that out in his new book the
value of a teacher over multiple years
definitely lots of interesting things
we're still learning about the uh the
human learning experience okay speaking
of that Emily's got a really juicy
question I'm just blown away by these
questions s these questions contain
entire essays within them Emily wants to
know how do you think AI should be
talked about within the general public
it feels like only those seeking the
information out for themselves are
getting a real feel for the
possibilities while news outlets focus
on doomsday scenarios or fluff pieces
what do you think is the right way for
us as a society to be talking about this
new
technology both you know I think at at a
high level I have a couple of Doomsday
fears um they're mostly things that are
out of my Direct Control uh but I do try
if I meet politicians or people who have
I try to tell them about it I am worried
about what a totalitarian government
might be able to do with generative AI
right now they can already listen to all
the phone lines but it's too much
information for them to make sense of
now they're going to be able to use
generative AI to listen on the phone
lines and then if anyone says anything
that they don't agree with you know they
can do bad things that I'm very worried
about I'm worried about deep fakes both
for manipulation uh you could imagine
all already this could happen I hope it
doesn't but someone could create videos
of people waiting in line outside of
their bank to get their deposits and you
know as they say what is it the you know
a lie can go around the world twice
while the truth is still putting its
shoes on um and and and and and so you
could C create a run on bank with
something as run on banks with something
as simple as that but then there's other
forms of deep fakes that can manipulate
politics Etc very worried about that
obviously for Crime fishing attacks with
the pH where you know pretends to be
some family member who needs money super
so those are that's the space that I'm
really really worried about I'm for the
most part very optimistic about what's
happening in education I I know the
honestly the biggest risk is cheating in
education I point out I have a chapter
about in my book cheating was already
there before generative AI you know
there's sites that will write a
student's essay for $ five dollar a page
and all of that type of thing and I
actually think generative AI is going to
mitigate that uh this is something we're
working on with kigo I hope we'll have
this in place in the next year or so
we're already creating essay uh tools
not to write your essay for you but you
could put your essay and'll highlight
parts of it and give you feedback it's
like having a writing coach uh where it
can give you feedback how you tighten
your argument etc etc in the next year
we hope to have it so that a teacher and
maybe even a parent can make an
assignment a writing assignment through
conmigo kigo is able to work to partner
with the student the student does all
the work but the kigo coaches the
student and then when the students ready
to submit their essay kigo can tell the
teacher oh well first of all here's the
essay but second of all we've worked on
it for about four or five hours we had
trouble coming up with a thesis
statement but we finally got there um
you know and Bas and by by the way based
on the rubric I would give it this score
and if a student went to chat GPT and
just copied and paste that essay in or
if they went
to um if their sister wrote their essay
for them or if they went to one of these
essay Mills on the internet and got it
written by someone in you know Nigeria
which is apparently where a lot of these
essays there's a lot of good writers in
Nigeria um then kigo will say I don't
know where this essay came from it just
kind of showed up um it looks shady and
by the way it's not consistent with the
students writing that I've been seeing
observing in their classroom so not only
can AI support students better but I
actually think can actually mitigate
some of the cheating uh that has been
there uh for for a very very long time
so I think there's going to be and if we
can save teachers time with lesson
planning and and and uh eventually
writing things like progress reports and
IEPs and Etc and and and these are
things we're working on right now expect
to see more in the in the coming weeks
or months um it's it's going to be it's
going to be real positive what I would
tell just anyone I I tell this to
everyone in my family I've told this to
young people out there looking for
jobs it's first of all no one should
stress it's still very early days I mean
just the fact that y'all are here or
that we're even talking about AI means
that you're an early adopter you're in
the you know top five per of people even
though it sometimes doesn't feel that
way uh but encourage people to just
start using it I'm encouraging everyone
at Conta just use it in your day-to-day
and maybe it's a little it'll slow you
down a little bit you're you know but as
you uh as you get used to it you'll
you'll start finding ways that it really
enhances what you do and discover a new
applications so you know that's I i'
I've encouraged young people to say like
hey create a um a prompt for uh
generative AI that kind of can represent
you almost can be an interactive resume
that'll impress employers like and and
you'll you'll you'll you know so things
like an interactive cover letter imagine
instead of a cover letter just being a
statement people can ask it questions
and it it represents you so there
there's there so I encourage people to
just start playing around with it seeing
if they can find it useful if you're
planning a vacation use generative AI
for that on kigo we have this thing
called for over 18 users we have chat
with gp4 um that's General you can do
anything you want there and then we have
all of the more special purpose things
that really try to fine-tune some of the
um some of the various use cases yeah
and just to show sort what s's talking
about here it's right there chat with
gp4 and um definitely be creative I
think s is absolutely right if you're
getting your hands dirty you're learning
so that's the best way and give us
feedback you know one one of the reasons
why we even put that there is one we
wanted to make that kind like One-Stop
shopping you shouldn't have to go
anywhere else kigo hopefully will have
everything you need but either if y'all
give us feedback or if we see wow A lot
of people are using this to say I'll use
Simple planification that's maybe not
core to education but they're using it
for this use case for runting a progress
report etc etc then that's a big signal
for us of like okay just raw gp4 is okay
for doing like that but let's let's
really engineer that and make it really
nice kind of like what we've done with
lesson plans and things like that this
is a great um segue to our next question
which must be from a an English teacher
actually because um this this question
ask her is worried about chat GPT kigo
all these llms actually eroding original
composition skills the ability to start
writing from scratch without that AI
scaffold is that something we should be
worried
about yes and no um I I I I I do agree
that there is something powerful in a
lot of creative fields of being able to
not be able to face a blank sheet
whether it's writing whether it's coding
whether it's painting that you know or
composing music that blank sheet can be
very intimidating um but it can also be
paralyzing for a lot of folks I think
there's a you know what we are
envisioning when teachers assign say a
writing assignment through kigo the
teacher can decide how much support the
students get um and we would never make
it so it writes it for the student but
um I think that could be almost like a
you know training wheels so that
students can feel the the joy of writing
and the productivity of writing and the
expression of writing without that that
cold start problem that cold start fear
but at some point you can start taking
the training wheels away so that they
really do feel like they you know they
they can they don't need something there
to talk about what's your thesis
statement going to be or let's outline
this thing together etc etc yeah it
seems like if you think back to
Elementary School ourselves every kid
learns with a scaffold you know write
your introductory sentence write your
you know next sentence your evidence so
in some ways it's just sort of speeding
up that process exactly giving a much
right you're exactly right I mean I'm
looking what my nine-year-old is doing
that's exactly it's it's very scaffolded
and if we can get that all the time with
the AI even even better here's a really
good question this dives into that CW
cheating again Aon wants to know is
there really any point in teachers
trying to catch cheating you know
there's this program originality a
trying to Market itself to teachers to
detect AI generated text should
Educators be spending energy on this I
think right now um anyone who well I
think there's two problems anyone who
tells you that they can detect AI
generated
text is is kind of not being genuine
with you um it can it can detect certain
aspects of AI generated text the problem
is and we've been hearing a lot I'm sure
many people here there's been a lot of
false positives and that's a pretty
horrible scenario to be in you're
accusing a a student student of cheating
when they didn't cheat um because this
isn't plagiarism it's not it's it so so
I I think that's not the way to address
the cheating issue my opinion is that
the way to address the cheating issue is
what I just described as like have kigo
work with you on the essay and then and
then transparently report back to the
teacher what it did and by the way
here's the whole transcript and if a
student goes to chat GPT or their sister
and gets it written kigos just say I
don't know where this essay came from
and it's not consistent with the writing
that is a much tighter way um and fairer
way of of measuring potential cheating
than having some kind of algorithm that
has a lot of false positives and you're
goingon to end up falsely accusing
students great um here's a juicy
question for you um someone is saying as
a father yourself what advice are you
giving your kids about AI today that
maybe other parents could learn from in
terms of how to guide their own children
on this
journey yeah and it's once again it's
still very very early days you know it's
not like social media where a lot of
kids are hooked on it and I have money
honestly much stronger opinions about
social media keep your kids off of it as
long as possible or or or heavily
regulated
um the AI you know we aren't yet seeing
kids addicted to Ai and hopefully we
never see them addicted addicted uh or
if they are it's it's in a good way you
know if you're addicted to Khan Academy
within bounds it can be a good thing
obviously you still go run outside and
have friends and all of that but if
you're learning that that could be a
good thing
um I think so I I I don't think this is
a time where where let's say a student's
using kmo and they're able to have
interesting conversations with kigo etc
etc as far as we can tell so far these
are very healthy things um and you know
I you know my my kids there's variation
some some of my kids love doing their
regular KH Academy and some of them not
not as much and I have to force it but
then kigo becomes a little bit of a
treat for example my nine-year-old it's
like a treat okay if you do your KH
Academy math for a bit then you can
write a story with kigo which he loves
to do and I know it's good for him
because actually when he's doing that
with kigo he's reading more too um and
he's so so I I haven't in in safe guard
railed sandboxes like we are trying to
build I haven't seen the downside yet of
of students just being allowed to do
what they want to do as long as there's
some some guard rails I I'll also say um
you know one of the things that we I
think a I know I'm sounding very
optimistic I'm not about everything the
totalitarian governments and crime
organizations Etc but one of the things
we are thinking about is kigo can start
to work Beyond KH Academy essentially
can be your co-pilot wherever you on the
internet as a parent it could be really
powerful from a safety point of view
um uh because if it's always there on
any page you go to you're going to you
know you're you're on Instagram you're
on um you're on YouTube wherever if one
the AI can make sense of what's on the
page and one decide whether it's
inappropriate or not uh as youall know
we already have an AI That's deciding
that on kigo and it's flagging to
parents and teachers if something's off
but you know so if you if a student on
YouTube and all of a sudden watches a
video that's inappropriate it can flag
parents it can even not allow the
student to watch the video if the
student is doing something that seems
good they're on you know they're reading
the news on New York Times or something
there still might be some stories that
aren't appropriate for them maybe it can
remove some soften some of the language
or maybe uh change it be closer to their
reading level or even better quiz them
on it so to make sure they understood
the underlying issues or you know any
background knowledge they need to
understand it um so I'm I'm optimistic
that actually um and I there's a chapter
about this in in my book where I
actually think thoughtfully we can have
ai almost like a bit of a guardian angel
for young people while they are on while
they are on the internet uh but you know
we're going to keep close tabs and
definitely let us know if you think some
negative Trends are are emerging amongst
young people yeah great call out and
speaking of young people we've got a
college student here who's asking for a
little career advice um he or she wants
to know um if they want to sort of like
hitch their career to the AI star what's
the best way to start doing that what
kinds of skills what kinds of
experiences should they should they be
developing today well I'll just double
down on the advice I gave about 10
minutes ago like if you want to hit your
wagon to the AI star start using it and
and and everything you do at minimum if
you're a college student I'm assuming
you're applying to
internships you know money back a
guarantee for the advice I'm about to
give you
but um if if you wrote
U an AI prompt that you know people
could go to and um interact with it but
it represents you and if in your cover
letter your resume you gave a link to
that I think you're going to get more
interviews because so many employers are
like thinking through what it they're
going to want to they want to be around
people who see who seem
to understand um the world that we're
going into or at least are leaning into
it and have an open mind and are trying
it out and even if you don't do that if
you just start playing around with it
and are able to write about that in your
resume or your cover letters and say
yeah you know I've I've been prompting
AI to do the following tasks I pretty
much use it to figure out what groceries
I should buy and whe that I think a lot
of employers are going to um take note
you know there's this whole field of
prompt engineering that literally didn't
exist a year ago um and it's it's it
pays well um and uh but it is a field
that you have to be ready to keep
adapting very very fast it's not like
you can learn some skills and just apply
those same skills for the next 50 years
um but if you're if you're the type of
person who likes that type of a
challenge yeah I there's there's so much
um there there's so much here I'll just
put in a little plug check out some of
our jobs at KH Academy because we
definitely can use some of those skill
we're hiring these job that's right um
great question from Ain about kigo um
Aon wants to know okay she's using it
with her own teaching needs today when
can she start using it with her students
how can she cross that Rubicon to get
access to her kids so right now uh you
know we call it kigo for classrooms
is it's something we're doing with out a
District by District level right now um
and we're ramping in fast uh so many
districts want to do this so that's one
option is tell your superintendent hey I
would love to be able to do this uh or
at least try it out or give us a l you
know so that's one um I think in terms
of you being able to do it on your own
uh you know uh Jeremy and I and a few
should chat about I would love to make
that possible um but those are those are
kind of the the the the two levers right
now but I don't know Jeremy anything to
add to that yeah it's definitely one of
these challenges of we're trying to
fight against this cost that we have to
pay to open AI into all of our you know
AI um uh resources to make it as
accessible as possible and so we're
going to be announcing some big news in
just a couple of weeks so stay tuned but
uh definitely a lot of big things coming
up at the end of this year and into the
start of the New Year yes as you can
imagine our mission is free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and
everyone here knows that kigo is not
currently free because of what Jeremy
just mentioned but a little
foreshadowing for the big news is we are
it's it's not going to be free just yet
but we are working feverishly to reduce
the cost so that we can make this as
accessible as possible Ain says we make
a great test subject so Ain we'll have
to follow up over after this uh yeah I
mean look if you can really make the
case we might anyway talk to J that's
right that's right okay here's this
isn't a question a little anecdote
Anonymous attendee says I ran something
I had kigo generate for me through an AI
detector like we were talking about
before and it came back is probably
human and something I wrote back came as
AI generated I told kigo about this and
it found it amusing so there you go kigo
has a sense of humor well I mean that
that's right there um you know it's
consistent with what I just said which
is just like these AI detectors are
snake oil as far as I'm concerned um and
they're false positives false negatives
um the reason why I probably didn't
detect kigos is we've worked as many of
you all know we've worked hard to give
kigo a humanlike tone um which most Bots
do not have uh but in some ways I guess
it's flattering that the a detectors
thought it was human yeah and then maybe
one last question to end on S this is
sort of like the Capstone is we talked a
little bit about the future of AI and
education all that but like what are
your hopes and dreams with this thing
like when you get excited about it's not
just the algorithm like what do you want
to see out there in the world through
this
technology oh
um you know you know the k a lot of
folks here know Khan Academy started
with me tutoring my cousins um as a
Pastime I I had a day job and uh I was
tutoring them word spreads in my family
free tutoring is going on I'm tutoring
1015 cousins I started writing software
for them that was the first cont Acy had
nothing to do with videos where I could
give them practice problems and keep
track of what they were doing that the
teacher dashboards were actually from
the very early days I was using it as as
my cousin's tutor um and then a friend
suggested I make YouTube videos and over
the last let's call it 10 15 20 years
everything that K Academy has really
been trying to do is iscale that kind of
personalization that you could get if
you could really have one to one and
every teacher on the planet every ed
school teaches differentiation every
teacher aspires to it but it's very hard
if you have 30 students in a classroom
people talk about pre-pandemic you had
three grade levels in the average
American classroom now there's six grade
levels of spread in the average American
classroom very hard for uh you could be
Superman or superwoman but to be able to
address the needs of of all of those
different levels um
I I think at minimum I hope over the
next couple of years you know kigo can
already do a lot as many folks already
know but it can it can take on more and
more of that real personalized support
when there's no one else there um to to
support them but connected to the
teacher I think that's key a lot of the
the the money that went into human
tutoring after the pandemic and you know
we as a country spent billions of
dollars on I think it was $86 billion in
hindsight people say oh it actually
wasn't that effective because it was not
connected to the teacher it was not
connected to their classroom and it was
for the most part logistically difficult
for a lot of kids to access it and
actually some kids were embarrassed to
access it this I think has the
opportunity to address all of that uh
it's available whenever folks want it it
can talk to the parents it can talk to
the teacher there's less embarrassment
for students using it you can connect it
to the work that the the students are
actually doing and I think you're going
to see it do sorry my dog's barking a
lot you're you're going to see it do
more of what a other things a good tutor
would do where it's you know call up
your parents and say hey this this
person hasn't been doing their work
lately we should problem solve this um
or uh or or or talk to the student in
that way uh or or give the the the
teacher more support and like hey here's
an idea what if we did this with this
group of students who seems a little
disengaged so that's very exciting if we
can really accelerate learning and
engagement it's
interesting already KH Academy if a
student is engaged the learning is we
have 50 plus efficacy studies so so it's
really all about engagement um and so
I'm I'm very optimistic there teachers
they have a million things to do um and
if we can save some of that lesson
planning grading rubric creation etc etc
time awesome teachers need it for
themselves and that's also more energy
that they might be able to you know help
help uh students with with all the
ideals we've talked about around
differentiation Etc so I'm excited about
that um I I'm I'm excited about broader
interpretation of assessment as we know
because assessment M have standardized
assessments have been narrow in a lot of
places the curriculum became narrow
because that's the only thing you can
measure I think that's going to change
as we can start to assess broader things
but still do it in potentially
standardized way I think you're going to
have a world where the space for
creativity like we've always talked
about Project based learning but it it
it's it's always been difficult um
especially if you're working with
younger students like what can they
really do that's going to be meaningful
in the world uh but now you know I've
said I thought the screenwriters Guild
is taking it the wrong way instead of
saying you can't use AI to to do some
screenplays they should be saying hey I
could use AI to be to not just write the
screenplay I could produce the whole
movie like like you know right now I I
write a great screenplay and I get a
small sliver and you know they spend a
hundred million dollars on it and all
these other people get all the money no
if you have a great idea for make the
whole movie and you know you're already
seeing with kigo students are able to
produce things that are better than they
would have been able to otherwise once
again all of that's transparent to the
parents and teachers so it's not
cheating Etc but I I think there's going
to be a lot of opportunity there where
um the creative output is going to
accelerate you're going to see a lot
more things happened that weren't I've
already I'm always giving you know Uncle
s is always giving talks to young people
and saying you know you have more
potential to have more outlets for the
world that any of us could dream of and
this was before generative AI this was
just with YouTube and social media you
can publish yourself generative AI is
going to take it to another level like
you can compose orchest Symphonies you
can you know anyway there's going to be
some some really cool things so I would
say that's going to be positive um I I
think on the internet and this isn't
just for young people if you think about
it pro the part of the problem with the
internet and social media is you have a
bunch of AIS that are working for
someone else and are manipulating your
brain in order to meet the needs of
someone else in order to increase their
revenue their ad clicks Etc I'm excited
because I think you know kigo and
generative AI is a co-pilot can be an AI
working on your side so when you're on
social media say hey Jeremy um aren't we
supposed to be working on this paper I
don't know if you should be looking at
your ex-girlfriend's marriage Jeremy
doesn't do that but you know at their at
their at their wedding photos uh you
know maybe we should get back to the
topic um or or or or or something like
or you know hey you know this isn't good
or my sense is that this is this is
actually fake news um this isn't you
know you should get a more balanced
perspective like imagine if we had
something with us all the time uh that
that was helping us bring us back to a
mentally healthier place and help
bringing Society back to a less
polarized place that would be a huge a
huge Boon um and I think there's ways to
counteract some of the you know just
just as a a a bad actor could use these
fishing attacks you could have ai that
answer the fishing attacks and try to
turn the tables on the just as a
totalitarian government might try to
Monitor and police people you could also
use generative AI a little mischievously
to make them distrust their Inner Circle
um so you know we we'll see that's not
that's above my pay grade but I I I
think it's it's going to be uh you know
AI technology is is neutral it's an
extension of human intent and as long as
the good folks use it at least as much
as the bad folks or more then we're
gonna have a better a positive outcome
from it well that's a super hopeful note
to end on especially as we head into the
holiday season um really good things
coming our way and thanks to everyone
for joining tonight um I love the
questions I love the energy and S thank
you for sharing your expertise and
wisdom here so just keep keep letting us
know keep feeding us what you're hungry
for in the new year and we'll keep
building for you thank you all so much
thank you s everyone have a beautiful
evening thanks every onward onwards